الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول عقب الضربات الجويه
ومقتل فلسطينيين انها عمليه عسكريه
استهداف مواقع وقاده بارزين من حركه
الجهاد اطلق عليها اسم السهم الواقي
مسؤولون فلسطينيون اكدوا مقتل ثلاثه من
قاده الجهات في الغارات ومدنيين بينهم
اطفال الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان ان
قواته شنت هجمات مركزه على القطاع طالت
عشره مواقع لانتاج اسلحه ومجمعات عسكريه
لحركه الجهاد وفق بيان الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وان العمليه التي خطط لها الثلاثاء الماضي
شاركت فيها اربعون طائره وقال ان ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد وهم قائد منطقه شمال قطاع غزه
في حركه الجهاد وقيادي بارز في الحركه
المسؤول عن توجيه نشاطات في الضفه الغربيه
انطلاقا من غزه وايضا امين سر المجلس
العسكري هذا وفق البيان الاسرائيلي
حركه الجهات قالت ان ثلاثه من ابرز قادتها
في القطاع هم خليل البهتيني وطارق عز
الدين وجهاد غنام قتلوا خلال الضربات
الاسرائيليه
متوعده بالرد وتكبيد اسرائيل ثمنا كبيرا
لعمليتها في غزه كما شددت على عدم مغادره
مواقعها في القطاع اما وزاره الصحه في غزه
فاعلنت انه اضافه الى مقتل واصابه العشرات
تعمل طواقم الاسعاف على اجلاء الضحايا من
المناطق التي تم قصفها
ومع استمرار التصعيد في غزه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه موافقه وزيرها على
استدعاء قوات الاحتياط حسب متطلبات الجيش
والحاجه لمشاركتهم في مواجهات محتمله جاسم
محسن العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات